National highways is warning of
hazardous conditions on roads in the
Southeast and east of England main roads
affected by the wintry conditions
include the M25 M11 M60 a63 a27 and a421
on the trains delays are likely
Southeastern says it's experiencing
severe disruption and thameslink
Southern Great Northern East Midlands
all have some cancellations and delays
at the airport's cancellations and
delays are happening at Heathrow Gatwick
Stansted Luton and London City airports
our chief north of England correspondent
Greg mylam reports
the first real blast of winter brought
its share of chaos to the roads drivers
stranded overnight on the M25 by the
snow and ice but this winter is also
bringing challenges that not long ago
would have been unthinkable
the winter deep freeze for many means
finding somewhere warm that doesn't mean
a huge bill the NIT and NATA in this
church is a welcome escape from the
anxieties of the price of energy they
have said that they might have blackouts
which is really scary for older people
and time to make do as they are I mean
because if they've only got electric
they've got no heating out there for
months we've wondered what would happen
when the first real cold snap arrived if
anything that shows us that if we don't
look after each other as a community we
some people are going to get left out
you know some people could end up on the
wrong side of poverty on the wrong side
of heat on the wrong side of hunger but
never mind affording the energy whether
there'll even be enough of it to go
around there's a question in itself
two coal-fired units at this power
station in North Yorkshire were put on
standby to be fired up again in the
event of a supply shortage there are
some circumstances under which you might
need to implement a temporary planned
control blackouts we are nowhere near
those circumstances at the moment and
and don't foresee being and US consumers
are being asked to do our bit as well
with another test of a scheme that
offers discounts for households that cut
their use in peak times
and this gonna turn this is a mini oven
which we use that more than the big men
of them Pam is unconvinced by the scheme
usually expect to have a evening meal
about six half five six o'clock
so depending on what they were promising
I just might say yes
but if it was make it inconvenience I'd
say no
already that challenge that so many set
of seeing how far they could get through
winter without turning the heating on
has gone out of the window it simply
isn't realistic in temperatures like
this winter has properly arrived and
this cold snap isn't over yet and as the
temperatures go down so the costs go up
navigating a cold spell like this would
have been tricky in any winter no don't
get out
disruption on the roads
oh
the inconvenience of canceled flights
for passengers like these at Stansted
Airport but this winter is challenging
like few in living memory
and for many
far from fun
Greg Milam Sky News